تثير هذه اللوحات التي رسمها صياد نجل الرئيس بايدن
مخاوف أخلاقية بشأن
العمل الفني لصياد البيت الأبيض الذي من المقرر
عرضه وبيعه هذا الخريف في عروض خاصة
ومدعومة فقط في لوس أنجلوس
في مدينة نيويورك
بسعر يتراوح بين 75 ألف دولار إلى
نصف مليون دولار
لكل قطعة يبكي بعض خبراء الأخلاق
قبيحة ،
فمن غير المعقول
أن يتم بيع هذا الفن من فنان غير معروف
بهذا
السعر إذا لم يكن اسم بايدن
مرفقًا به ،
فإن الخاتم الذي يأتي مع شراء هذا
الفن هو ما يقول  أنت تمتلك
الفن الذي أنشأه نجل الرئيس
ويتفق بعض نقاد الفن
على أنني أقول لأول مرة أن
الفنان بعيد قليلاً
عن النطاق مع الأسعار العادية ، إنها
لوحات عامة إلى حد ما تعرف
أنها ربما تكون ماهرة تقنيًا
بطريقة معينة  لكن ليس لديهم
أي
جاذبية وراءهم أو الحياة من ورائهم ،
تقول المصادر لـ CNN إن البيت الأبيض
قد شارك في تشكيل صفقة بين
مالك معرض سوهو نيويورك
الجغرافي.  rge burgess و hunter biden
لمحاولة معالجة
أي مخاوف أخلاقية ، يقول مصدران مطلعان
على الترتيب أنه لن يكون لدى الصياد
بيدن أو الإدارة
أي
معرفة بمن قام بالمزايدة أو شراء العمل الفني
، فسيتم عدم
الكشف عن هويته وإذا كان هناك أي سلوك غير عادي
مثل  سعر العرض مرتفع جدًا
، ومن المتوقع أن يرفض المعرض
العرض ، والإجابة الصحيحة هنا هي
الموافقة علنًا على الكشف عن أسماء
هؤلاء
المشترين ، وكان بإمكان الجمهور في هذه الحالة
تتبع
ما إذا كان هؤلاء المشترين يحصلون على وصول تفضيلي أم لا
مقابل دفع مبالغ فاحشة
في بداية عهد إدارته ،
تعهد رئيس إدارته ، بايدن ، بتجنب حتى
تصور تضارب المصالح ،
إليكم كيف أنظر إليها ، قلت إن الخط الفاسد
على بعد 15
قدمًا من السلة لا يجعلني
أقترب من 17 قدمًا
لأنه  هي حقًا
مسألة ثقة الجمهور اليوم ، أجاب البيت الأبيض
على الأسئلة حول بيع
فن الصياد
بعد الحذر  في الاعتبار ،
تم إنشاء نظام يسمح
للصياد بايدن بالعمل في مهنته
ضمن ضمانات معقولة أعتقد أنه
سيكون تحديًا
لشخص مجهول لا
نعرفه ولا يعرف الصياد بايدن أن
له تأثيرًا ،
لذا فهذه حماية على
سيرة صياد موقع المعرض لا
تذكر أنه نجل
الرئيس
بدلاً من ذلك بالتفصيل أسلوبه الفني
ووصفه
بأنه شخص كرس
حياته الفنية للفنون البصرية
في الماضي ، كان الصياد مفتوحًا
في معركته مع إدمان المخدرات و
اقترح أن الفن يساعد في
إخبار نيويورك تايمز أن الرسم
يضع طاقتي نحو شيء
إيجابي ،
فهو يبعدني عن الناس والأماكن
التي لا ينبغي أن أكون فيها ،
هذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
يطمس فيها أفراد عائلة الرؤساء
الخطوط الأخلاقية بيلي بير في  روج
بيلي ، شقيق رئيس السبعينيات جيمي كارتر ، شركة
بيلي بير ومؤخراً
لعائلة ترامب
بينما كان الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في أو.  حصلت إيفانكا ترامب على أكثر
من عشرة براءات اختراع من الصين
بينما كانت الولايات المتحدة تتفاوض بشأن صفقة تجارية
مع الصين
سونلين سيرفاتي سي إن إن واشنطن